- Welcome to our session.
My name is Felix, I'm the product owner
for the Accelerate and Compute at Nvidia.
I'm gonna get started.
So today we have a full agenda,
there's lots of stuff to talk about.
We're gonna introduce a little bit
about the RAPIDS Accelerator first, right?
And then my friend here from
FINRA is gonna talk about FINRA
and their story around people
who leverage the technology
and accelerate their workload.
So without further ado,
just go get quickly
into the context here, right?
Apache Spark is one of the most popular
data processing framework out there.
It's basically used by almost
every single enterprise
and organization out there
for a number of different
kind of needs, right?
Whether it is just doing
analytics, reportings,
or even machine learning, you see.
But more importantly, data is growing
at this crazy exceptional
rate in the last couple years.
So obviously in the last year,
maybe more for AI and all of that,
but it's definitely growing
at a exceptional pace.
So in order for enterprises, organizations
to be able to kind of handle
this exceptional growth,
we're introducing kind of
the GPU acceleration factor.
So what you see on the
right hand side here
is a stack, right?
So you have the Apache Spark workload,
basically Spark application
running here as is.
We are introducing a plugin
that you can kind of install
into the workflow itself,
with no code change,
and then leveraging the
hardware acceleration layer,
the GPU you see, running
on the cloud or on premise,
and then get you the cost
saving and faster result.
So even though the GPU might
cost some amount of money,
it's not really a whole lot,
but the acceleration is so much
that basically you get
your data, your result,
faster and cheaper.
And so that's kind of what we focus on.
And to give you an idea, these
are the kind of companies
and enterprise organization
that's kind of gone public
to talk about their
use of this technology.
In the last two years or so
there are definitely more of that,
but, so you can kind of see a pattern,
like online services,
retail, financial services,
and that's kind of more
relevant today as well.
So I can give you a little bit more,
one other example here,
especially around fraud detection.
So with fraud detection,
oftentimes you have the process
like billions and
billions of record, right?
You go back like five
years, 10 years, 15 years,
kind of looking at patterns.
That pattern is actually using
time series windowing
operation and analysis.
And that's actually something
that's really good with GPU.
And so as a result, we're
able to get 14 times speed up,
in this particular case,
this type of workload at 80%,
well 90% saving.
And if you want to take a look at this,
we actually partnered with
AWS FSI team last year
to make this post.
You're welcome to use this
QR code, open up the webpage,
take a look at it yourself,
kind of what it looks like,
and we'd love to kind of be
in touch with you as well.
So without further ado,
we'd like to introduce
our friend from FINRA here to
talk about their experience
working in this technology.
I'm super excited to actually talk here,
because last year it's our presentation
actually what got them interested in this,
and this is how we were working
together to work on this.
So.
- Perfect.
Thank you, thank you Felix.
Thank you for the great
introduction on Apache Spark RAPIDS
running on Nvidia GPU chipset.
I'm Alain Menguy, the
senior director of big data
and performance engineering at FINRA.
I've been working for FINRA
for more than 20 plus years,
and I can tell you that I've been involved
in many transformative
and innovative project
and this one, Spark RAPIDS on GPU
is absolutely one of them.
Yeah, so first, who is FINRA?
FINRA has been around for a while.
We were celebrating our
85th anniversary last year.
Our mission is twofold, market integrity
and investor protection.
We are making sure that
all the participants
can trade with confidence,
and that the market operate
free from market manipulation
and fraud.
Basically, what we are
doing, we are protecting you,
as investor, to ensure that
your money is safe and sound.
So the nature of our business
make us an AI and a big data company.
We are operating over
1000 petabytes of storage
in the AWS cloud.
In March this year, we
process a peak volume
of 1.5 trillion market
event for a single day.
Yes, I repeat, 1.5 trillion
market event in a single day.
Processing this volume
require a massive
technological infrastructure
and sophisticated system.
So quickly, our business flow,
after the market closed
at 4:00 PM Eastern time,
the member firms have the obligation
to report their trading activity
before eight o'clock the next day.
From there, we have only few hours
to reconstruct the market activity.
Then we are gonna run
hundreds of pattern model
looking for market manipulation and fraud.
It generates alert if
it finds some anomalies,
and those alerts are sent
to our investigator team,
then they can interactively
query the system
to get a better understanding
of those alerts.
Market volume keep going up,
and over the year has
been growing dramatically,
and the trend, that is still gonna go up
the next couple of years.
Modern electronic trading platform
and high frequency trading system
generate far more transaction than before.
And as volume scales up,
so does the computing need
to handle that volume.
Our challenge is not only business logic,
it's also scale and cost efficiency.
And that led us to evaluate
the GPU acceleration option.
As you can imagine, FINRA
needs to constantly adopt.
We cannot stand still.
We are always looking for
ways of new capabilities
that will reduce the cost,
improve the performance
and the concurrency, as well
as strengthening our resiliency
and security, and whatever we adopt
must make performance and economic sense.
So as you know, AWS and
the open source community
are constantly releasing
new hardware, new services,
and new execution model.
So for us, evaluating this innovation
is not something that we do once a year,
it's part of our DNA.
This is something that
we are constantly doing.
It's not about chasing shiny object,
it's about deciding which
EMR version, or Java,
or Spark we will be using.
This ongoing benchmarking
guide our architecture roadmap
and platform decision.
So at FINRA we rely on
the benchmarking suite
that blends industry standard
and real FINRA production workload.
We use TeraSort to stress large scale IO
and TPC-DS to evaluate SQL
planning, joins, and aggregation.
We are also benchmarking things,
six of our regulatory workload
with very large data set, heavy shuffle,
and complex join pattern.
So for the sake of time,
I will skip that slide,
but understand that we are
doing a fair comparison
between the runs.
We have the same input data dataset,
we have the same Spark configuration,
the same cluster
configuration between runs.
And of course we validate the output.
We are making sure that
the result does not change
between the runs.
So this is really the
Moore's law in action.
Look at the performance
improvement over the years.
Just from the natural
evolution of EMR, Spark,
Java and underlying hardware.
Those are the results for our
TPC-DS nine terabyte benchmark
that we've been running
through all those years.
No code change, same data, same logic,
just newer Spark version, newer engine,
and newer instance families.
We went down from nine
hours five or six years ago
when we were using EMR 5.24,
to one hour and 45 with
the latest EMR 7.10
that was released just few weeks ago.
That's a five times
performance improvement.
And you can imagine the cost reduction
by jumping on those new technology.
This is really the Moore's laws in action,
and that's where Spark
GPU entered the stream.
So this is a slide that I
believe I saw a few months ago
on the presentation from the Nvidia team,
and it really caught my eyes.
We are early adopter in the cloud,
our first workload on
the cloud was in 2013.
Back in the Hadoop era
we were using Apache Hive
in order to run our query, our SQL query.
Then Apache Spark came along
and changed the game in memory processing,
gave us a major leap in
speed and efficiency.
So then when I saw that
slide, I said, "Oh, oh, oh,
this is really speaking to me."
So is GPU accelerated spark
the new leap in technology?
So that's what we want to try out.
So let's use TPC-DS nine terabyte,
and wow, breaking the one hour mark.
From 53 minutes exactly
in order to run the exact same workload
that was running for one hour
and 45 minutes on EMR 7.10
and the latest RHGD instance type.
That's roughly 50%
performance reduction in time,
processing time.
And it's also roughly 50% in cost saving,
because of course the cluster is running
for a shorter period of time, so faster,
cheaper, without doing a code change.
So that moment I say, "Well, let's do it
on some real FINRA production workload."
So that's one of the case
that we are having here.
This is not synthetic,
this is real FINRA production workload.
The total input of this
data set is 11 terabyte.
And this pipeline is really a join heavy
and shuffle intensive.
We are joining two very large tables,
50 billion record in each of them.
One of them has 125 rows,
columns, and the other one has 25.
And we are joining the
key by processing debt
and some row ID which is
one of the business logic
in our application.
Here, of course, the data is
partitioned by trading debt.
We didn't change the code,
so this application is return in Scala,
and then we run this
application on CPU and on GPU.
And again, what we see blew our mind.
Again, 50% performance reduction
and lower cost of around 45%.
No code change.
And this is really where
we start to say to ourself,
there is something that
we really need to explore,
because this is mind blowing
from a performance and
cost saving opportunity.
So the one of the key takeaway
that I want you to remember is,
we didn't just switch the flip,
flip the switch in order to enable
that massive performance gain.
On our first try, the GPU
run ran for five hours.
So then we did contact the Nvidia team,
we had a very good collaboration
between the two engineering
team in order to identify
what was the bottleneck.
We explored the plan.
We saw that sometimes the GPU
was falling back on the CPU,
identify a bunch of bottleneck,
and the Nvidia team came
up with a new plugin
based on those finding
on this special workload.
So a key takeaway, I
say yes, no code change,
but it's not plug and play, not always.
Then another workload.
So this is the key data extraction.
I've been telling you
that the member firms
are submitting their file to us.
So they're sending CSV.bzip2 file.
We need to decompress
them, we need to read them,
parse into type columns,
and then from there we
need to convert them
to a Parquet format
using the Snappy protocol
compression format.
Firms are sending us a
hundreds of thousands of files
on the daily basis.
So this is an application
that is gonna run
quite a few times over a single day.
So here again, iteration process,
at first CPU, GPU, we were even,
and then again we collaborate
with the Nvidia team
in order to identify the bottleneck.
And what we've seen is that
the original application
is using the dataset API,
and that was not really a
good use case for the GPU.
So we had to transform
to a data frame API.
And by doing this, by
doing multiple iteration,
we were able to reduce the time by two,
and then at the end of the day by 10.
So, which was a major improvement,
but again here, very strong collaboration
with the Nvidia team in order
to arrive to this result.
So key takeaway, we look at
benchmark, industry benchmark,
and we look at some FINRA
production workload,
and what worked very well was that yes,
we were able to get two times
faster join at lower cost
on some of the workload that we try.
RAPIDS integrate very well with SQL
and data frame pipeline,
no code change in some case
were needed for some pipeline.
And yes, the run time and the
cost saving were consistent
on switching up the configuration.
What was hard was the GPU
memory has some limitation.
The spill to this needs to
be managed very carefully.
Some operator fall back to CPU,
creating mixed execution plan,
and the RAPID configuration
is not straightforward.
You know, open source is a
little bit finicky and tricky.
So one change in one parameter
can do some dramatic
performance improvement
or sometimes performance down.
And also one of the issue was
the GPU instance availability.
It's not always easy to get them,
especially if you require,
if you need hundreds of them.
So we need to establish
some relation with Nvidia
in order to be able to get our capacity
for those type of workload here.
So where are we heading?
So I think this is the end
of the first proof of concept
that we did with the GPU
and Apache Spark Rapid.
So not every workload get advantage,
or you are gonna need to spend lot of time
in order to identify
what is the bottleneck.
Now we have a process
where we can validate
the CPU versus GPU execution time.
So we have a process to test more.
We are hopeful that GPU
evolve from experimentation
to a strategic performance level,
based on the performance
benefits and cost reduction
that we've seen.
This is an evolution for us.
We are gonna add GPU and Spark Rapids
into our big data workload stack.
However, today CPU remain our default,
but GPU certainly will be
our future accelerator path.
And I'm right on time.
(Alain laughs)
Perfect, so thank you,
and we are happy to take question.
Oh, there's one more one.
Here we go.
- [Felix] You're welcome to try it out.
This is the URL.
You can go in and welcome to contact us
in this email as well.